Hello everybody, my name is (static) Markiplier and welcome to UmFend. Now UmFend is...
... a love story?? About...
Something
Hmm, don't like that at all... anyway. We're gonna. We're gonna remember now
I don't know what we're remembering but...
Something tells me we forgot it for a reason and maybe we should just leave well enough alone and go about our daily l-i-i-ives *glitch*
Oh boy, Oh?
2005... OH I was deep in my World of Warcraft days in 2005!!
Wait... No was it wasn't even out yet!
I can't even remember now. No! No that's not right I was in cities of her- a city of heroes
That's when I was playing okay. What is this?
*giggle* P-put the seeed!
I don't know about that one. I don't know about.. no.. it's being filled with fLeEr!? *giggle*
Oh, yes! *giggle* The five basic food groups: grains, fruit, vegetables, meat, FLEER!
Okaaay...
Water the plant *more Markigiggling*, I don't know - I don't know what that is over there... OOH
Did I get a battery or is that chalk?
It needs batteries. Well I put one in.
I don't know what I'm supposed to do with the rest of it. Oh, this is bizarre. Oh, I don't like this
Oh crystal emitting strange waves many charged particles
FLEER: DON'T *giggle*DRINK IT
What's FLEER?! To do: find batteries, water the plant, bring the seed, pour the fleer. WHAT'S FLEER??!!
The fuck is fleer?!?!
I mean I've already identified what fleer is, but you know... I just want to know what you guys think fleer is.
Okay
Alright then, ahh... ohh
Is this my hooome?
Maybe.
This looks like, uh...
And there was a game that I played a while back that I really really loved; it was pixelated in almost this exact - ehH-
Oh, it's a branch. At least I hope it's a branch! It's a branch-armed monStER! Oh.
Okay, yeah, I can't remember what it's called right now, but it was really good. I'm wondering if this is made by the same people
Okay! (heavily sniffs air) No, I don't like that!
Ooh! That's marginally better! OOH floppy slippers!
Ooo! Cup to use for fleEr. Oh, I hope anyway. Let's fill the cup up with water! *singsong*
Okay, maybe not! That was ju- I got some water in my cup. I'm so happy about that fact!
Okaaay, I guess I'm done here. Can I - OK there we go. Is this the fleer I've heard so much about!
You can't go in here, you can't turn on that light. Okay!
I think I got everything that I neeeeeed!
I got baaatteriiiiies (Yay!)
I can water the plant now. Maybe I've got a box of seed, and then some fleer!
Doot, doot, doot, doot!
Wow...
WOoOW!
OoooH! WHAT!? Oh, fleer!
I shouldn't drink it. I really shouldn't, but I really need that fifth fruit group. Oh
Watered! Ohh..
That's a little too green. I don't think a plant's supposed to do that!!!
Put the seed... I DON'T HAVE NO SE-E-ED!
I don't have any of this so-called
SEED that you're talking about. Is there a seat around here that I'm not seeing??
That for some reason -  oh good a skateboard! I can get all radical and slide on out of here
Yeah, that's what the kids say, right? They- when they're skateboarding like "we're gonna get all radical with our FLEER!"
We're gonna go chug some FLEER and get radical on our skateboards!
Yeah, fellow kids?
Is that what you say? WE say? is that what we say, fellow kids? oh?
There it is! How did I miss you?
It's so NOT tiny and...
Impossible to see. I have the seed now!
And I shall put it on my device that I built and I know what fleer is
Time to get radical!
Oh, that's not good.
I don't like that. No that's probably- that's- that's one of those "not good" things!
Should I push the button? Aah, this button! Big button!
Boink!
OOOHHhh
Um! Maybe we shouldn't be messing with the interdimensional amoebas..
Maybe that's uh- maybe that's a big 'ol no no
Ooh! WAAA!! Ookay- oh nnnoh
(Mark?)
(You mkay?)
"Reset the power in the kitchen..." might as well give myself a big old glass of FLEER while I'm....
Oh no, even I can't limbo that low! I'm not radical enough! Uh-oh
All right.
Well, hopefully nothing's gonna happen on the way to the kitchen.
Where would I... is this the fus-e box-o?
Mmm... kerchunkles? wooh!
All better in this neighborhood.
*creepy giggly bitch entrance*
Um hi. Hello, I know I'm hilarious, but you don't need to laugh so eagerly.
*wimpers like a wuss*
Okay, all right, (multiple "woah"s and "OH"S)
(more "woah's" and "OH's"...)
ooooh
ooh
Um. I'm here. I will return to you... (rereads)
I will return you. To restore: the cable, the core module, battery, the crystal. We have time to talk...
I don't wanna ta-a-a-ha-ha-alk
I don't want to talk. What did you do with my Fleer? Oh you stole all my FLEER?
oh no... (giggles more)
Okay, I gotta go find some... batteries
oooh
That wasn't there-
Oh, that's a hyuuman.
Or not a human!
Oh, what are you?
Hi!
Hello!
OOOHHHHHHHhhhh
okay
All right
I have nothing to say about that
I am sure that that is fine!
and I am fine!
and everything is fine...
What is that...?
Has that-
Has that painting always
been like that?
Have I always
had a weird mushroom
on my-
counter-
-top..?
-thing?
*gasp* Nope, nope nope nope nope nope
Just gonna turn that-
okay
alright
well...
*whale ungulating noises*
mmm
Don't like that... oh...
Okay, no batteries in here that I can see
Batteries in here maybe? Oh. Oh! Door open! Oh how helpful. Ugh...
How not helpful clicky clacky? oh
Okay
Don't trust this at all. There's definitely something bad happening here. I don't know want to know what that rat tail is
Hmm. Oh, it's a rope rope here
All right nothing else? nothing in the laundry. Why did I get rope? I don't know why I got rope- AUGH
All right time oh that's not good oh
That's Oh
Hi
No, no, no, it's some PT bullshit up in here
Oh, no. No, no don't be sniffing me, and I ain't got your FLEER. Well you go get radical out of here
oh
that star oh oh oh oh
that's not good
Are you in my hair? Are you and my precious, beautiful hair, what did you do?
Haven't actually tried the door well I guess it-
Wha-HEY
I Told you no sniff snoffing, don't you be sniffs snorfing all over me. I know I smell really good, but
Hey, I don't know which way to look
About one of these? is that gonna do it for you? is this on lockdown? nope okay well alright then
People anymore babies crawling around the ceiling huh any more babies?
Alright, you know I don't like those ceiling babi- Oh
Well I
Didn't find a goddamn dick diddly thing that I needed except some rope and I still got my slippers
But I don't think that's gonna help me
Alright, can I reset the power? no, ok alright time to go see what new message is on the board!!
Yeah, is this supposed to be something. I don't think so I don't think that's anything.
Nothin, all right. What do you got for me my skateboard still there?
Ok oh the cable the cable. I don't even know- ok the cable is restored
Hey
How you doing how you doing
Buddy do you remember me? No, you know?
What no I don't I don't remember you at all, but I want to,later and another time. Oh trust me
I really want to know you
What's so wet and slips slapping over here who's slip slapping?
That's not good. Oh, that's not good
I think I still got that baby in my hair, but that's alright
Don't know about that one
Why does it sound like someone's crunching bones in here.
Hello?
Anybody in here?
Okay
You think I'd have some sort of internal monologue about the strange is happening in my own home, but alas I do not
Think your new you're gonna lock me in here again is baby gonna crawl out of toilet. Oh
That's not good
That's not good at all. Oh, that's not good. Hey hey
Um my shit, don't get my Fleer you stay the hell away from my Fleer
I don't think those are supposed to be on the ceiling there's a lot of things on the CI yeah, ah shit, ah
shit, you know I
Don't like your habit of putting my shit and babies on the ceiling. It's not good. It's not nice our
That's not right
Something tells me that ain't right
Okay, all right. What else you got in store for me is the bathtub on the ceiling - no, okay, all right?
Then well, I guess I'll just mosey on back to my home
Can I
No, all right. Well. That's locked so is there something in the the new kitchen design that you
Think that I should know about oh the faucets on well. That's obviously the most incorrect thing in this place
Miss save some water if there's one thing I always keep in mind when my life is in imminent peril is I was concerned
oh
All right then
Conserving power is also a very intelligent thing to do Oh
Celie God why am I suddenly checking the ceiling for ceiling babies you put this fear and mate um
Umfend oh, it's not oh, that's
That's really not good
All right oh, no not another ceiling, baby all right go, okay. Well Oh
Oh remember remember remember remember remember remember did you
Forget me apparently I did you know
Apparently you think I would have remembered some kind of ethereal horror like this, but you know you know how it is I get busy
Busy with life busy with forgetting woo
That's not good. I don't like how there's a forest of leaves in my living room
Not my ideal still locked okay?
Why'd it get quiet?
I knew you were up to something you dick oh
Okay, all right. Oh now. I can read it clearly. Oh now. It's less threatening against my life
Thanks for turning the lights back on no oh
No(X2)
No(X4)
No(X5)
Turn these I liked it better when it was quiet. I'm gonna go
Hmm oh good
You've put my chairs back in their proper places. I'm so happy about that. Hey battery. Well. That's handy
I hope I only need one
Cuz god damn it. This is not
Pleasant okay, turn that on okay all right. Well. I got a battery I
Wish I didn't turn out the light cuz I can't see shit
Okay, well there it is huh Wow much better okay? Hello
you got my frill, I'm
Anita all right Anita
Okay, I'm battery connected I
Just need some Flair
Okay, the core module and the crystal well. I'm halfway to insanity. Let's keep moving, huh?
All right, oh, hi. Well. How are you Anita?
Hello
How's it going
Fair fair thee well, okay, well that's not right hmm, and I just wanted to pop a squat
maybe watch some Netflix with you, but
Alas it looks like okay. You are taller than I remember you being with longer arms
I don't like that at all very slender s. Can you get out of my fridge? Hey, that's
Okay, okay. Well I?
Know I don't keep a well-stocked fridge
No
Is that a cat
What is it?
It's a cat oh no no no
That's not, I don't remember buying that I have no idea how that heart got it my friend
I was holding it for a friend friend
Least I got this nice shapely carrot
Sausage just close that lets clue. Can I close that nope okay? That's open now. I don't know why that heart was meowing oh
That's not good. Well. Oh
Can't be any worse than anything I've seen already so I guess I'm mentally prepared for whatever dick 'try you're gonna throw at me. Oh
Oh, no. I wasn't ready. No. I was not ready. Give me a hammer. Give me a hammer please
Okay do I still have time to get radical out of here? Oh?
My knee babies you know mini babies also known as bugs. Oh, that's that's not good
That's what I would go not good all right well. That's a problem
Gonna have to call an exterminator for that one. It seems like there might be uh
Might be something I need to take up with landlord
right well
Doesn't seem to be do bad, and it seems to have solved itself okay heart OH
Or is that a drawing of a butt I never know which
Okay, well so far so not bad
No, not today. Is that a meat cleaver or something?
No hi
Okay, who are you?
Don't you remember me? No I don't. Tell me who are you?
The girl you ignored at school well alright then
At school I've been beside you for 11 years
What do you want from me?
You don't remember me at all?
At all. There were articles about me in newspapers like I read
Newspapers come on lady. I always dreamed that you would look my way
I wanted
You to pay attention to me. Well, you could have said hi I mean if this is your way of saying hi very original uh
Nope, nope no. No no no don't want it. Yeah about past part pass hard hard pass
Frankly I think I remember why I didn't look your way at all, mmm. Well. That's a problem
Okay, well uh must be Oh
Okay, never mind. Then let me just go ah what a wonderful
Day, ah want a good nap nothing to worry about here. Oh
fuck ah
I would have been time to go back into my workshop
Doodly doodly doodly Doo oh?
Boy, oh, man. I'm hungry. I'll take I think I'll go get a snack for you
Okay, I'm just gonna go to the bathroom
Oh man after a nice nap I could use a
That's better gotta wash my hands, no time to get myself a cup of coffe
No you stole my chair, Oh box
Just for me all for me
That's all for me. Oh you shouldn't have well this
empty like my own
Empty like my heart and my soul
Mmm. Good time to take your nose bath question mark Oh yep, it's bath time
But I don't want to take that bath. Oh a bath. Don't look too good
Some right. Somethin aint right about that bath
Okay
God what did you do that to me? My nose? You broke my nose?
Why would you do that?
Why'd you do that huh why would you do that hmm, let me put my core module in there's a heart box
Yah, oh
Come on don't futz with my Fleer my fleerrRRR
Man I worked so hard on that fleer all right then
What else do you want from me mm-hmm
Hello?
I hear someone futzing with the radio in there
Please don't I have it set to my favorite station, and I don't know how to change it back
All right then
Am I supposed to go back in here?
No, this is still weird alright. That's still weird good to know
And now it's open now. Why is it open?
Why
(Mark contemplates why with rambling)
Singing detected whoa
How will you return to me? How die what you think I forgot?
how do
You uh?
how die?
You need to work on your grammar
Oh you went to school for 11 years, and this is the kind of grammar you come up with some don't add up
hmm, that's right
Okay turn that off
Okay, never mind
You fuddled with my radio what I told you not okay something seems to be happening with the colors
My eyes seem to be failing me in this super darkness
Hmm Oh
What is that Oh?
crystal oh
I've got the Cristal!
Got the crystal you got it here in my hand
Don't know what it is kind of some weird moving
bullshit okay
I guess we're just gonna well. That's not right
Got some weird moving bullshit here just gonna put ha that's not right
Got some weird moving bullshit. That's not right
Ok got some weird moving bullshit
hmmmmMMMMMMM
Time to put the crystal back, I guess ok did it I need to launch it into the Sun
Do I need to launch this whole shit into the Sun do I need to do that?
because I will
Okay, I did it FLEER go go FLEER. Go go go go go FlEerr. Oh
hmm, okay
Am I supposed to step into that
hmm again?
Again with this bullshit you think I forgot. Oh, you still broke that on my wall. Oh, it's not good
I don't have a floor with my flashlight
Oh
No no no no no no
(Where's popcorn wnen you need it?)
Okay, I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it. Oh it tingles. How it feels weird ah oh that's not good
Okay
(Oh-ing intensifies)
Beautiful, I love Minecraft okay here we go
1996 so this was nine years ago, okay?
Hello oh, hi hello
That was it oh man
It was so good oh, so good that was so good
I love that that was so well done ummph and great game. Love it. Love it. Love it. Ah
terrifying terrifying very very scary ah
It's so good. Humphhh end was delightful really really it was honestly delightful
I liked it a lot, and if you guys want to play for yourself
maybe there's something I missed but I'm not a hundred percent sure there could be anything that I missed I'll put a link in the
Description below other than that this was a great game the developer did a great job at this
Also, the tasteful nudes calendar is still on sale for only
24 more hours, but good news you guys as of this recording have already raised over
$200,000 to the Cancer Research Institute through that calendar that is an astonishing
astonishing
Amount of money, and we're not even done with the sale yet
Please if you haven't gotten a calendar yet
Clicking the link in the description below check it out for yourself all the proceeds that I would get go towards the Cancer Research
Institute I don't make a penny off of this. It's all for a great cause and I'm not fully nude, so it's it's alright
It's good. Anyway. Thank you everybody so much for watching. Thank you. Everybody there's bought a calendar already and
Thanks for watching and as always I will see you in the next video
Buh bye!